en décembre 2011 une collaboration de
chercheurs de google et stanford annonce
un résultat spectaculaire
après avoir entraîné leur intelligence
artificielle à extraire la sémantique de
vignettes youtube
ils ont découvert que cette ia a
réinventé le concept de chats de toutes
les découvertes en ya et il y en a eu
énormément au cours de ces dernières
années même si elle est vieille cette
découverte du concept de chat par unia
est de loin celle que je trouve la plus
incroyable
oui parce qu'on y réfléchissant bien ça
en dit beaucoup sur le potentiel de dia
mais aussi sur le fonctionnement du
cerveau humain et même sur la nature de
la réalité
avant d'aller plus loin j'aimerais qu'on
s'arrête d'abord sur une question
d'apparence tout simple qu'est ce qu'un
chat si vous avez bien suivi cette série
vous devriez sentir venir le piège
en fait dans l'épisode 6 on en avait
déjà parlé j'avais alors prétendu que
les notions de chat de souris ou de
volonté du chat de manger la souris
étaient toutes des notions extrêmement
complexe si complexe qu'il est
humainement impossible de les définir
alors ça paraissait osé comme
affirmation donc je vous invite à la
méditer un peu plus longuement
comment définiriez vous ce qu'est un
chat une approche récurrente chez les
biologistes de l'évolution pourrait
consister à s'appuyer sur l'arbre du
vivant
on parle d' approche phylogénétique
typiquement on peut considérer un chat
et affirmé que les parents de ce chat
sont des chats ainsi que les autres
enfants de ses parents mieux on peut
considérer que tout ancêtres de ce chat
est un chat et que tous descendants de
cet ancêtre est aussi un chat on obtient
ainsi toute une branche du vivant qui
correspond au concept de chat bien sûr
ce raisonnement sur les chats fonctionne
aussi sur les éléphants les papillons
les mammifères les rattes obtenu où nous
autres humains et le gros problème avec
ce raisonnement c'est que si l'on
accepte le fait que les parents d'un
chat sont des chats ont conclu
nécessairement que l'on peut remonter
indéfiniment l'arbre du vivant jusqu'à
ses origines que non puisque on sait
aussi qu'il ya quelques milliards
d'années il n'y avait aucun animal sur
terre et donc pas de chat en fait
aussi étrange que cela puisse paraître
affirmé que les parents d'un chat sont
tout autant des chats que leur enfant
est logiquement incohérent comme
l'expliqué dirty biology comme
l'évolution d'un organisme est le fruit
de petites modifications graduelle
il n'y a pas vraiment de début strictes
à une espèce pas deux premiers
bidule en remontant notre généalogie
tout ce qu'il y à trois cent mille ans
on ne retrouvera pas deux premiers
humains en trouvera des gens qui avaient
à la fois des caractéristiques de non
humains et d'humain bref toute tentative
pour définir le début de l'humanité est
un problème insoluble
et si vous voulez être radicalement
logique on devrait admettre que le
concept dumas n'a pas vraiment de sens
réel puisqu'on ne pas y trouver de début
clairement défini sable tout comme le
tas de riz n'est pas un tas parce que le
concept de ta n'existe pas en soi dans
la nature nous ne sommes pas humain
parce que le concept d'humains et dans
nos têtes mais n'existe pas en soi dans
la nature
la définition du concept d'humains et
purement arbitraire site une étiquette
que nous nous sommes à coller mais qui
n'existe pas vraiment en dehors de nos
esprits
ça paraît osé comme conclusion quand
même non le concept de chats seraient
ainsi pire que faut il serait
logiquement incohérent et du coup a
fortiori il ne ferait référence à rien
de réel alors bien sûr j'ai choisi de
parler de chat pour ne pas heurter les
moeurs mais ça soulève d'autres
questions similaires
qu'en est-il de l'identité même du chat
ou de mon identité personnelle
a priori le même argument semble tenir
pour l'existence de l'est pourtant
clairement au moins moi j'existe
non l'idée que le moi n'existe pas a
fait son chemin
l'un de ses défenseurs les plus connus
est au xviiie siècle le philosophe
écossais david young la certitude
absolue n'est pas que moi je suis moi
j'existe comme le soutien des cartes ego
soum ego existe au mais simplement il y
à des perceptions et de laâyoune tire la
conclusion finalement assez naturelle
mais assez dérangeante que nous ne
sommes rien d'autre que cela mais il
faut bien noter que guillaume n'est pas
aussi radicale que le bouddha il
n'invite pas les hommes a visé un
nirvana où nous serions enfin libéré de
cette illusion du mois j'avoue il a pas
l'air de viser le nirvana ce bon david
certes ce que nous appelons mois n'est
en fait qu'un faisceau de perception en
perpétuel changement sans unité sans
simplicité sans permanence donc pas du
tout un mois finalement mais pour autant
nous n'avons peut-être pas tort de faire
comme si il y avait une telle unité de
la désigner par ce mot mois cette unité
est fictive donc le mois est une fiction
mais c'est une fiction utile à toutes
sortes de choses par exemple utile à la
survie de l'organisme ou utiles à
l'organisation sociale
mais si les concepts de moi ou de chats
n'existe pas s'ils ne sont que des
fictions quel est ce concept de chaque
liées à de google a su identifier
avant de répondre à cette question je me
permets une petite note léo thibault et
moi avons pris des exemples de notion
relativement simple pour vraiment bien
illustré la difficulté de fournir des
définitions de concepts qui nous sont
familiers
mais bien sûr ce que l'on dit là
s'applique à toute sorte de concept
comme le disait le logicien bertrand
russell tout est une vague d dont on ne
prend pas conscience
tant qu'on n'essaie pas de rendre les
choses précises et j'irai même plus loin
en affirmant que rendre précis des
concepts aussi complexe que
l'intelligence la démocratie où la
notion de chat est une tâche si hercules
yens qu'aucun humain ne saura y parvenir
dès lors il ya deux façons de faire soit
on choisit une définition rigoureuse qui
ne collera pas complètement voire pas du
tout à l'intuition
soit on se contente de définition floue
et on tient compte de ce flou artistique
dans nos discussions informelles dans
cette série jusque là pour parler des
concepts difficiles du langage humain
comme celui de chat je me suis contenté
de définition floue en fait je n'ai même
jamais défini le concept de chat et ce
n'est pas forcément problématique je
pense que personne n'a été choqué par
mon utilisation du mouchard tout comme
personne n'a été choqué par
l'utilisation du mot structure par david
ceci étant dis aujourd'hui on va réussir
une sacrée pour s je vais enfin vous
présentez une définition rigoureuse de
ce qu'est un chat même si cette
définition ne coïncident pas entièrement
avec notre intuition pour cela à
revenons-en à l'ia de google et stanford
intuitivement pour qu'une ia puisse
montrer qu'elle connaît et comprend le
concept de chat il faut et il suffit
qu'elles puissent toujours ou presque
toujours disons nous dire si telle ou
telle chose est un chat ça commence à
être pas mal
reste que l'ia n'a pas accès directement
à la chose elle ne peut analyser que des
mesures indirectes de la chose
typiquement une photo de la chose et
d'ailleurs on peut rajouter que cette
limitation désir n'est pas du tout
spécifique aux machines au final quand
on dit ça c'est un chat ce qu'on dit
surtout c'est que l'image que nous
rétine enregistre fait activer nos
neurones d'une certaine manière pour
nous amener à dire que les excitations
des capteurs de noureddine s'explique
par la présence d'un chat alors certes
nos capteurs ne se résume pas uniquement
à l'activation des neurones de nos
rétines
nous disposons de toutes sortes d'autres
sens comme le dorat le toucher ou louis
ils peuvent nous donner des sensations
qui seront elles aussi compatible avec
l'existence d'un char mais au final
toutes ses sensations toutes ces mesures
faites par nos sens il ne s'agit ni plus
ni moins de données de données qui
conformément à la théorie de
l'information de shannon correspondent
ni plus ni moins à une longue suite de 0
et de 1
du coup il semblerait que le concept de
chats ne correspond à rien d'autre
qu'une fonction qui prend en
considération toutes sortes de données
diverses et variées visuelle auditive
olfactives ou autre et détermine si ces
données révèlent la présence d'un chat
en tout cas c'est clairement à cela que
correspond le concept de chat de l'ia de
google et stanford
revenons-en à leur expérience ils ont
donné un réseau de neurones artificiels
toutes sortes de vignettes youtube a
analysé l'objectif du réseau de neurones
fut d'extraire une sémantique de ces
images c'est à dire de calculer une
compression grossière de chaque image en
une poignée de concepts abstraits point
de vue technique il ya plusieurs façons
de faire cela et comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer la proche de google et
standford août 2011 a été largement
surpassé depuis notamment parlé d'
générative adversaire yole networks ou
games dont on reparlera dans cette série
mais ce n'est pas de cet aspect
technique dont j'aimerais parler
aujourd'hui
tout ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que
l'ia de google et stanford est un réseau
de neurones composé de couches chaque
neurone de la couche d'entrée est
connecté à un espèce de capteurs
sensoriels qui va mesurer la luminosité
d'un pixel de l'image
chaque neurone effectue alors un petit
calcul
puis en fonction du résultat du calcul
envoie ou non un signal ou neurones
deuil seconde couche chaque neurone de
la seconde couche collecte des signaux
de neurones de la première couche
effectué un petit calcul puis envoie ou
non un signal à la couche suivante et
ainsi de suite
et bien ce qu'ont découvert les
chercheurs de google et stanford c'est
que leurs réseaux de neurones disposait
d'un automne qui s'activait si et
seulement si le réseau était exposé à
une image contenant un chat alors ce
n'était pas exactement ainsi et
seulement 6 mai le taux de succès était
de 75 % ce qui pour 2011 était vraiment
impressionnant aujourd'hui on fait bien
sûr beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mieux
dès lors le concept de chat pour leurs
réseaux de neurones correspond à
l'enchevêtrement des connexions
neuronales qui conduisent à l'activation
ou non du neurone chat sait tous partie
du réseau de neurones correspond alors à
une fonction qui prend en compte une
donnée et détermine si ces données
correspondent au concept de chat eh bien
on peut considérer qu'il s'agit tout
simplement là de la première définition
rigoureuse du mouchard que l'humanité
ait su rendre explicite et bien sûr les
réseaux de neurones plus récent
correspondent à des définitions
rigoureuse encore plus juste du concept
de chat alors ça peut vous paraître
bizarre que je parle d'un réseau de
neurones comme étant une définition est
en effet ce n'est pas usuel mais c'est
pourtant bien le cas
pour le comprendre il suffit de jeter un
oeil au code source de ce réseau de
neurones ce code source contient toutes
les instructions à suivre pour
déterminer si une image est une image de
chat ou pas en suivant pas à pas à ses
instructions
on obtient ainsi un mécanisme qui va
nous permettre de conclure si une image
est une image de chat en langage
algorithmique la définition d'un concept
n'est donc autre qu'une fonction
calculable qui prend des données
sensorielles et conclut si elles
correspondent aux concepts ou non alors
bien sûr si suivre les instructions du
réseau de neurones est possible en
principe la définition qu'on obtient est
loin d'être exploitable surtout par un
humain
en particulier un mathématicien va avoir
bien du mal à prouver quoi que ce soit
avec cette définition
reste que c'est quand même fou quand
vous y réfléchissez nous a fallu faire
du dip learning pour enfin éclair des
définition rigoureuse du concept de chat
ceci étant dit en un sens il existait
déjà dans notre univers des définition
du concept de chat vous voyez de quoi je
veux parler
oui je parle de vos cerveaux vos
cerveaux ne sont finalement pas si
différent des réseaux de neurones dont
on a parlé aujourd'hui il analyse des
données sensorielles pour déterminer la
présence ou l'absence de chat la
structure de vaud cortex cérébraux
correspondent donc en un sens à des
définitions du concept du chat mieux
encore les neurosciences ont montré la
présence dans nos cerveaux de neurones
qui reconnaissent le concept de chat ces
neurones et chats vont s'activer si et
seulement si nos données sensorielles ou
provoquer un torrent d'activation
neuronale qui forcent l'activation des
neurones chat ainsi la définition de ce
qu'est un chat selon un humain données
ne sera autre que la fonction que calcul
l'enchevêtrement des neurones du cerveau
de l'humain qui conduisent à
l'activation ou non de certains neurones
chat de l'humain d'ailleurs les
neuroscientifiques ne se sont pas
arrêtés au concept de chars comme
l'expliqué stéphane sur home au fabuleux
zones du cerveau qu'on appelle le lobe
temporal médian et qui se trouve à peu
près là ou sur le côté du cerveau
derrière l'oreille les chercheurs
trouvent un neurone qui réagit tout le
temps aux images de jennifer aniston ci
lui présenter une image de bill clinton
pas de réaction une image d'araignée pas
de réaction une image de la tour eiffel
pas de réaction peu importe que jennifer
aniston soit en train de sourire de
pleurer ou en train de griller des
chamallows devant un feu de camp le
neurone s'excite peu importe que
jennifer aniston soit présenté en gros
plan en plan large en plongée en
contre-plongée le neurone s'excite donc
c'est comme si le neurone nous disait
peu importe la façon dont il me présente
jennifer aniston tant que je reconnais
que c'est jennifer aniston je m'excite
est doublement plus intéressant le
neurone ne réagit pas qu'à des images de
jennifer aniston il réagit aussi aux non
jennifer aniston écrit sur un écran et
il réagit aussi aux non jennifer aniston
prononcer à voix haute
donc ça montre que c'est pas un neurone
qui réagit à des stimuli visuels
spécifiquement c'est un neurone qui est
bien plus générale que ça c'est un
neurone qui réagit au concept de
jennifer aniston
donc si je récapitule selon le
formalisme qu'on a étudié aujourd'hui un
chat n'est autre que l'activation d'un
certain neurones du un torrent de
signaux initiée par certaines données
sensorielles et le concept de chat n'est
autre que la complexe connexions des
neurones qui vont des données
sensorielles ou neurones chat mais
surtout à moins que la fonction ainsi
calculé par les réseaux de neurones
artificiels ou naturels ne soient
grandement compressibles il ya de bonnes
chances qu'il s'agisse là de la fonction
la plus simple que l'on puisse proposer
au concept de chat or ces réseaux de
neurones sont tout sauf simple du coup
toute définition rigoureuse du mot chat
qui soit créé au nab le mans juste a de
bonnes chances de faire au moins des
millions de pages voilà pourquoi j'ai
parié sans flipper que vous ne saurez
pas fournir de définition de chat avec
laquelle on sera tous d'accord à moins
de copier/coller le code du réseau de
neurones de google et skype ford ou
d'une autre ia de ce genre avant de
passer aux commentaires je vous rappelle
qu'il y aura un youtube live mercredi à
17 heures pour la conférence de thibaut
vion il d'ailleurs si vous êtes à
lausanne près de lausanne
je vous invite à venir assister à la
conférence en direct et en renfort de
live dans la salle à le pfl et pour cela
il faut vous inscrire l'inscription est
obligatoire et venez nombreux
si cet événement marche très bien ça va
me permettre
d'organiser d'autres événements de ce
genre et faire venir d'autres grand
vulgarisateur à le pfl la leur en a
parlé de l'algèbre de la sémantique
notamment de cette équation assez
perturbant trois mois en plus femme est
égal à rennes etienne didot une demande
comment du coup si on prend des mots de
langue étrangère comme queen the rain
comment est-ce que quelle est la
relation avec le vecteur rennes
en fait comme je l'avais expliqué dans
l'épisode 21 il ya une relation entre
l'espace de sémantique on pensait les
relations de sémantique en anglais et
cette relation est une son appel niveau
maîtrise à dire une application linéaire
entre l'espace de sémantique anglais
espèce de sémantique français qui
préserve notamment le produit ce qu'elle
est et ça ça veut dire en particulier
que l'addition est préservée à travers
cette transformation
c'est pour ça que si on traduit mot à
mot eh bien on a encore l'égalité dans
l'espace sont des scientiques en anglais
en fait originalement bien sûr les
papiers de recherche est un écrit en
anglais
cette relation était en fait en anglais
on avait en fait kingman haussmann poste
baumann est égal à queen
ceci étant dit le fait que ce soit une
mise aux métriques en particulier
produits scolaires soit qui me servent à
venir conserver après cette
transformation ça signifie qu'ils aient
une ressemblance encore plus forte entre
les deux espèces de sémantique et ça ça
me permet de rebondir sur la question de
kamikazes qui demande que représente
notamment la norme des vecteurs bien la
norme d'un vecteur c'est sa ressemblance
avec lui-même déjà se dire que l'angle
entre l'un et l'autre est égal à zéro
c'est reculer pour son antique vous
rappelle que lang mesure la ressemblance
sémantique entre les mots mais ensuite
la taille des vecteurs aux présentes
également quelque chose de particulier
puisqu'il s'agit en fait plus ou moins
de la fréquence du mot un mot qui a une
grande norme c'est un mot qui est
souvent utilisé dans la langue en
question du coup le fait que l'on
cherche une mini sommet tri entre les
deux espaces de ces antiques en anglais
et en français signifie aussi qu'on
cherche à préserver l'importance des
mots dans le langage tellement ils sont
utilisés ainsi que la ressemblance entre
différents bons kamikaze une demande
comment sont traités les mots flou j'ai
quand même un peu plus loin avec
notamment l'épreuve d'homonymie ces
harkis et des moqueries fils qui
s'écrivent pareil et qui ont des sens
différents et bien dans ce cas avoir tué
considérera que la représentation
vectorielle du mot sera en fait une
certaine moyenne pondérée
deux des différents sens possibles des
mots ondes et réparer l'importance
d'utilisation des mots par exemple si je
considère le mot chat est bien la
plupart du temps c'est correspond à
l'animal mais peut-être que les temps en
temps ça correspond un jeu comme chat
perché où je sais pas pourquoi
et dans ce cas temps en temps ce mot
chat va être utilisé dans un autre sens
sauf que bien sûr la plupart du temps le
mot chat renvoie plutôt à l'animal du
coup la représentation électorale du mot
chat sera une moyenne entre le vecteur
animal chat animal est le vecteur chat
dans un jeu mais comme le mot chattant
sens animal et plus vont utiliser la
représentation vectorielle du mot chat
sera beaucoup plus proche du chat animal
en fait on peut utiliser des techniques
un peu plus sophistiqué pour essayer de
distinguer les deux sens du mot chat
pour savoir en fait dans un contexte
donné si ça correspond plus probablement
au mot chat animal ou homo chat chat
perché dont quelques uns même si la
représentation vectorielle du moche à
strictement parler et de une certaine
direction
si on le regarde dans un contexte donné
on saura si c'est plutôt dans ce sens où
dans ce sens poule box et en diminuant
rade à manta pose la question de la
dimension de l'espace de sémantique on a
vu 1 ère fois que l'on considère des
expressions et tics de dimension environ
300 typiquement et ça ça veut bien dire
comme il explique que concernèrent il ya
une base de la sémantique qui est un
ensemble de 300 éclore et en os tout
autre vecteur est une composition de
combinaisons ou linéaires pour être
précis de ces trois vecteurs de base
c'est assez amusant de se dire que du
coup en fait à partir de 300 notion
fondamentale on peut d'une certaine
manière construire toutes les autres
notions de la sémantique
alors bien sûr c'est pas forcément juste
ça tirait commencions north
mathématiques on aime créer des concepts
qui sont pas dans le langage courant et
du coup il faudrait revenir à augmenter
l'espace de sémantique pour pouvoir
discuter d'autres concepts c'est ça va
suggérer vraiment l'idée que cet espace
de sémantique en pratique en fait il
faudrait qu'il soit en plus dynamique et
que nous servent à niort ce qu'on
souhaite voir tuer qu'on a juste une
première étape une première
approximation d'un espace de son antique
qui serait
seulement beaucoup plus complexe que
cela si je devais parier je dirais que
la recherche en intelligence
artificielle devra s'équiper des espaces
de ces antiques dynamique
potentiellement ou variable mais bon
tout ça c'est un niveau de la recherche
non pas seulement actuelle mais à venir
et je suis sûr qu'il ya encore beaucoup
de découvertes à venir dans cette
recherche en intelligence artificielle
vincent bien réagi sans doute aux yeux
zine à l'image de la femme qui a été
inventée de toutes pièces par
l'indigence artificiel du coup il
imagine peut-être des élections en train
de fantasmer alors faut savoir que l'ia
qui a produit cette image a été
entraînée uniquement sur des images de
stars de cinéma
du coup forcément les images qui sont
générés sont représentatifs des stars de
cinéma et pas forcément de la population
globale mais je dis cette question pour
revenir sur un autre truc un papier
récent qui l'a de 2018 je crois qu'ils
parlent d'unia qui est capable de jouer
à des jeux vidéo et de fantasmer sur les
jeux vidéo c'est à dire que après avoir
joué un petit peu au chat vidéo elle est
capable se reconstituer une
représentation simplifiée du jeu auquel
elle joue et en rêvant du coup elle est
capable de jouer la version qu'elle
imagine du jeu donc en fait elle est un
peu une simulation du jeu à l'intérieur
d'elle-même et elle joue à cette
simulation du jeu pour pouvoir
s'améliorer et se préparer au moment
elle jouera vraiment au jeu et c'est
assez amusant et c'est complètement
facilement fou comme façon de réfléchir
et c'est sans doute très lié à la
manière dont on apprend vraiment à jouer
aux jeux vidéo enfin je sais pas si les
jeux notamment sur téléphone auquel vous
êtes un petit peu éthique mais sans
doute quand vous rêvez du coup vous vous
rêvez parfois en train de jouer à ces
jeux et je pense que de façon plus
générale c'est comme ça vraiment qu'on
apprend bien c'est à dire que peut-il qu
en maths pour pouvoir devenir bon en
maths je pense qu'il faut être capable
de se servir à avoir une certaine
représentation abstraite simplifiée des
mathématiques et de s'imaginer de rêver
être en train de jouer à ces jeux parce
que ça permet justement de trouver des
liens et de simplifier les calculs nous
tentons de trouver des eaux ristic pour
faire référence à la conférence que
j'avais donnée las il ya quelques
semaines à le pfl notamment si on a une
version similé du jeu on peut faire
plein de calculs approché pour essayer
de trouver des bonnes restic pour
résoudre les problèmes
dans le jeu ou dans les mathématiques
pour qu'ensuite lorsqu'on soient
confrontés à un autre problème
mathématique au jeu en vrai contre un
nouveau joueur on soit armé de toutes
sortes doris tic qui sont capables de
réagir à toutes sortes de problèmes que
que l'on rencontre en temps réel et
ensuite lorsque l'on résout rapidement
du coup ces points d'eux parce qu'on on
dispose d or et styles qui ont été
entraînés grâce à la version simuler on
paraîtra sur une main ou très
intelligent et tout ça mais en fait
finalement tellement les facultés en
mathématiques correspondent 200 autres
pas mal à cet entraînement que l'on a
inconscient lors de nos rêves face à des
problèmes mathématiques simuler et qui
nous permettrait ensuite à dun de donner
l'impression qu'on est en fait très fort
en maths alors qu'en fait c'est juste
beaucoup de travail inconscient qui est
derrière tout tout tout ce génie supposé
en mathématiques
enfin sv où tu vas y je sais pas comment
il faut prononcer le signal que en fait
tu vas y toi aussi fais plein de
l'association assez tranchants gêne
quand j'en repars ce billet de blog qui
parle de nos traditions formé par watt
une action assez étonnantes ou
discutables
on va dire mais en tout cas voilà c'est
l'espace de ces antiques qui a été
appris par intelligence artificielle
suite à son analyse du langage naturel
et l'une de ses mains des calculs un peu
troublant dérangeant qu'a découvert
world check et le calcul médecins -
sommes plus femme est égal à infirmière
sur ça correspond pas vraiment à ce
qu'on aimerait ce qu'on voudrait en tout
cas que ce soit comme calcul mais il
faut bien se rendre compte qu'il s'agit
là d'un calcul fond d'une relation entre
ces différents vecteurs qui a été
déduite d'une analyse du langage naturel
dire que la manière finalement dont on
utilise l'humour infirmières en pratique
malheureusement il à dire ça correspond
à l'équivalent de l'utilisation du mot
médecin lorsqu'il s'agit d'une femme
c'est très dérangeant et c'est pas
forcément souhaitable mais encore une
fois c'est vraiment une analyse
sémantique de langage naturel et ça veut
dire aussi qu'un enfant qui apprend le
langage naturel en écoutant ses parents
parler ou en écoutant venise ont des
journaux je sais pas trop quoi arrivera
à ce genre de conclusion et du coup on
aura des biais inconscient sur ces
opportunités plus tard notamment et ça
montre vraiment comment le langage
structure notre pensée comment
l'utilisation de certains mots dans
certains textes peuvent nous amener à
avoir des bien conscient sur tableau des
billets de genre puisque clairement
c'est bien les deux joueurs ne sont pas
du coup tout spécifique à l'humain est
alors tout ça c'est très problématique
pour l'humain parce qu'en plus l'humain
est très difficile à corriger mais
peut-être que les ja l on peut les
corriger de sarnia et les amener à
penser les trucs qui sont plus désirable
malgré j'ai envie de dire les données
auxquelles on les expose et c'est toute
la problématique de façon plus générale
de programmer les la morale des liens et
c'est ce dont on va parler dans les
épisodes à venir en tant qu il s'agit
d'un problème de société a absolument
crucial et qui va peut-être même
déterminer le futur de nos civilisations
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
cette vidéo conclut donc cette mini
série à l'intérieur de cette série sur
lire sur la sémantique on a quand même
vu des trucs incroyables de cours des 4
dernières vidéos mais la prochaine fois
on va passer à un truc un petit peu
différente puisque comme vous
sentez venir avec ses vidéos on sent qu
en fait les ja ont énormément progressé
et finalement beaucoup de choses à nous
apprendre voir
vont nous aider de plus en plus à
organiser nos sociétés en ce cas elles
sont déjà en train de complètement
bouleversé la manière dont nos sociétés
sont structurées et à partir de la vidéo
précédente
on revient sur des trucs beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup plus compréhensible
puisque on va parler du rôle désir dans
nos sociétés et des changements
sociétaux à venir à cause de désir et de
tout ce que seront mis en cause dans la
structure d'une société en particulier
pris sans embarras de la singularité
si vous avez aimé cet épisode
essentielle de l'ikea la commenter à le
partager pensez à vous abonner von kant
et futurs épisodes narcy un petit peu à
peu leurs dents et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois sans doute
est il plus raisonnable de faire avec ce
mois ce mois fictif n'est utile tout en
gardant dans un coin de sa tête cette
petite idée dérangeante obsédante
presque inconcevable et pourtant tiré
flux table qu en réalité non non tu
n'existes pas tu n'existes pas tu n'es
qu'un flux de perception sans aucune
unité est ce que le neurone jennifer
aniston est fidèle à jennifer aniston
est ce qu il ne réagit que pour les
images que jennifer aniston
la réponse est non la plupart des
neurones tester réagissent à plus d'un
concept
par exemple le neurone jennifer aniston
réagissaient également au concept de
lisa kudrow est une autre actrice de la
série friends ou le neurone qui
réagissait au concept de luke skywalker
est assez juste c'est également au
concept de yoda de neurones de la tour
eiffel réagissaient également au concept
de la tour de pise
or réagir à des concepts qui sont liés
c'est une propriété intéressante parce
qu'on peut imaginer que ça aide à créer
des liens entre les différents concepts